partons maintenant pour l'ouest de
l'ukraine pour la ville de lviv sept
cent mille habitants depuis le début de
l'offensive il est devenu en quelque
sorte la capitale de l'ouest ukrainien
des ambassades comme celle de la france
s'ils ont été déplacés c'est par elle
que transitent vers la pologne la
dizaine de milliers de personnes qui
fuient la guerre nous retrouvons sur
place notre envoyé spécial tarek haye
bonjour tarek est ce que pour se
déplacer elles vivent est une ville sûre
elle vivre est un lieu sûr même si la
tension reste très palpable dans la
ville ce qu'on peut dire c'est que eux
jusque là donc la ville a été épargné
par ces frappes russe
par ses frappes depuis le début de
l'offensive les sirènes donc
retentissent de temps à autre dans la
ville pour nous rappeler que la guerre
n'est pas très loin d'ici rien qu'hier
soir c'est sirènes ont retenti peu avant
l'entrée en vigueur de du couvre-feu qui
commence à 22 heures et qui se termine à
6 heures poussant les gens donc à se
réfugier dans les abris ces sirènes qui
retentissent donc de temps à autres ne
sont pas les seuls à pouvoir alerter la
population il ya chaque habitant ou
presque dans cette ville à une
application sur son téléphone une
application qui a été développé par le
ministère de transformation digitale une
application développée en quelques jours
et qui est très présente ici et qui
alertent justement chaque citoyen de de
cette ville vivent ou d'autres villes
ukrainiennes de l'imminence du frappe et
du besoin de se réfugier dans les abris
autre signe de cette tension et la
présence de la police et de l'armée en
en ont maintenant la ville il est rare
qu'on nous demande pas à longueur de
journée de présenter nos pièces
d'identité le but étant à chaque fois
d'éviter la présence de d'espions ou
d'agents russes qui serait selon les
autorités locales capables de commettre
des actes de sabotage ou même de
transmettre des informations de grande
importance il est aussi important de
souligner que la ville de lviv est
devenu une sorte de capitale
diplomatique de l'ukraine puisqu'un
grand nombre d'ambassades étrangères
s'est relocalisé ici même elles vivent
c'est le cas de l'ambassade de france
mais c'est le cas de nombreux autres
ambassades donc pour répondre à votre
question oui ils vivent reste un lieu
sûr mais la question est de savoir
jusqu'à quand la seconde question paraît
qu'on se prépare au scénario peut-être
le plus pessimiste qu'est-ce qui est
mise en oeuvre pour cela
après plusieurs jours de combats
effectivement on s'attend au pire mais
tous ceux qui sont restés dans la ville
et qui n'ont pas décidé de partir que
soit en pologne ou dans d'autres villes
ou dans d'autres pays européens ne reste
pas les bras croisés de nombreuses
initiatives des dizaines et des dizaines
d'initiatives citoyennes ont été lancés
dans le but de participer à cet effort
de guerre que ce soit pour aider la
mairie crânienne ou pour se défendre
contre l'armée russe pour soutenir de
l'american yann par exemple certains ont
créé des ateliers de confection de
camouflage qui seront envoyés à la mais
c'est ce camouflage donc serviront à
cacher les chats ou d'autres véhicules
militaires dans ses ateliers qu'on avait
visité hier ses ateliers ressemblent à
de véritables fourmilières où des
dizaines de jeunes ou même de personnes
âgées seraient les nuitées jours pour
confectionner ses camouflages pas
entravée par exemple et de l'avancée des
chars russes certains même produisent ce
qu'on appelle les hérissons tchèque et
qui sont censées entre avait donc est
constitué des obstacles devant l'avancée
des chars pour s'attaquer à l'armée
russe certains ont transformé des
distilleries de bière artisanale en des
ateliers de confection de cocktails
molotov on le trouve un peu partout dans
la ville dans des associations de
quartier et ça c'est aussi très présent
donc vous l'avez bien compris tous les
moyens sont bons ici pour participer à
cet effort de guerre merci tard et
tailles envoyé spécial de france 24 à
lviv dans l'ouest de l'ukraine merci on
va parler de kiev